bienvenidos a un vídeo más y estamos en
el examen número 3 en la sección 2 y
bueno
estamos en el problema número 15
entonces déjenme apuntarlo por aquí
estamos en el problema número 15 que
tiene dos triángulos así que vamos a
dibujar dos tengo uno por aquí tiene una
base parecida a ésta y tengo algo por
acá y después hoy creo que no esto no me
va a funcionar
tengo algo por acá y después tengo algo
que baja como por acá perfecto este es
uno de ellos y después tengo otro
parecido a éste
solamente que creo que no son iguales
esto va algo así y después esto se ve
algo así y después esto se ve algo así
más o menos se parecen a estos
triángulos y me dan algunos datos me
dicen que este es el triángulo am
c mientras que éste se llama d
efe y que otra cosa me dan me dicen que
este ángulo vale x este ángulo vale
también x este ángulo vale james este
ángulo valley en esta distancia vale 5
esta también vale 5 y esta distancia
vale org
ok y el problema dice más o menos así sí
que es igual a 60 grados
james es igual a 60 grados muy bien que
tanto mayor es el perímetro del
triángulo y b6 al perímetro del
triángulo d
efe
changos cómo resuelvo este problema y no
me gustaría utilizar funciones
trigonométricas nunca hemos utilizado
funciones trigonométricas así que no
creo que vaya por ahí a ver pensemos
este ángulo vale 60 grados este también
vale 60 grados si este vale 60 este vale
cuánto vale este
pues este vale 60 120 o claro este vale
también 60 grados este vale 60 grados es
decir que este triángulo el triángulo de
e efe es equilátero es que la pero este
triángulo equilátero porque todos sus
ángulos miden lo mismo y por lo tanto
todos sus lados miden lo mismo este lado
mide 5 este también va a valer 5 y este
también va a valer 5 propiedades de los
triángulos equiláteros esto está de lujo
por lo tanto el perímetro de este
triángulo es igual a 555 lo cual es 15
el perímetro de este triángulo es 15 ok
vamos a fijarnos en este otro triángulo
en este nuevo triángulo no me dan el
valor de x no sé cuánto vale x pero si
me dicen que este ángulo y este ángulo
son iguales cuando tengo este ángulo y
este ángulo igual me refiero a un
triángulo isósceles
a bs es un triángulo isósceles y solo
isósceles es decir dos de sus ángulos
son iguales y por lo tanto este lado y
este lado tienen la misma longitud en
los triángulos isósceles siempre estos
dos lados tienen la misma longitud y por
lo tanto esto vale ocho y así ya podemos
calcular su perímetro el perímetro de
este triángulo del triángulo abc es 8
más 85 lo cual es igual a 16 más 5 21
muy bien y yo lo que quiero saber es qué
tanto mayor es el perímetro del
triángulo abc que el perímetro del
triángulo de efe y bueno la respuesta es
el inciso c que es igual a 6 21 menos 15
y 6 el perímetro de este triángulo es
seis unidades mayor que el perímetro de
este otro triángulo por lo tanto ya está
mi respuesta es el inciso c así que
vamos a borrar esta pantalla para hacer
un problema nuevo
estamos ahora en el problema número 16
el problema número 16 y dice lo
siguiente si x y ya son enteros impares
consecutivos y además se cumple que ya
es más grande que x lo que me preguntan
es cuál de las siguientes expresiones es
equivalente a que cuadrada menos equis
cuadrada yo quiero obtener una expresión
equivalente para y cuadrada menos equis
cuadrada amperios en que x y jenson
enteros son impares y son consecutivos
eso es muy importante sí que es el más
grande entonces puedo ver alguien como x
como x + 2 para que sean dos números
consecutivos e impares
entonces me tengo que ir de dos en dos
por ejemplo si x vale 5 y yo le sumó 2
entonces ya valdría 7 si x vale 3 y yo
le sumó 2 entonces lleva
cinco son impares consecutivos el
siguiente imparte 5 -siete el siguiente
imparte 35 por lo tanto el siguiente
imparte x es x + 2 le estoy sumando 2a x
para obtener el consecutivo y sigue es
igual a x + 2 am bueno esto lo podríamos
ver como yemas x por jay menos x pero
realmente todo esto parece mucho más
confusos y habló de una diferencia de
cuadrados a no me voy a complicar más la
vida y mejor voy a ver esto como la
siguiente expresión
cuadrada menos equis cuadrada es lo
mismo que llevarle x + 2 por lo tanto
esto es lo mismo que x + 2 elevado al
cuadrado
- x cuadrada y si esto lo elevó al
cuadrado pues es un binomio cuadrado
perfecto y me quedaría cuadrado el
primero
dos veces el primero por el segundo 2x
por 2 es 4 x más cuadrado del segundo es
decir más 4 ya esto le voy a quitar esta
x cuadrada menos equis cuadrada de tal
manera que éste y éste se van y me queda
que esto es lo mismo que 4 x + 4 y ahora
déjame ver si esta es una respuesta que
estén mis incisos perfecto si es el
inciso en el inciso me dice que esta
expresión es equivalente a 4 x 4 aquí
está mi respuesta así que un problema
menos ya estamos cerca de acabar esta
sección vamos al siguiente problema el
problema número 17 el problema número 17
que me dice
y habla de rectas son las 6 30 de la
mañana antes del día de gracias y
realmente debes de apreciar mi
disciplina mi esposa por ejemplo es
médico residente y ella tuvo que
trabajar 36 horas el día de ayer así que
llego a casa y esencialmente pasó de
largo olvidó el día de gracias
de hecho olvidó todo y justo después
ella tuvo que regresar a trabajar de
nuevo
ella tiene como 12 horas de turno está
loca solo le queda este último año y yo
espero con ansias que esto acabe pero
una vez que pase esto probablemente
habrá menos vídeos de matemáticas una
vez que tenga mi esposa de vuelta en fin
de cualquier manera regresemos a las
matemáticas
estamos en el problema número 17 y dice
en el plano xy la recta l
pasa por el origen y es perpendicular a
la recta a déjame apuntar datos a ver
dice que tenemos una
a él en la cual por cierto pasa por el
origen pasa por el punto 00 ok
am y esta recta l es perpendicular es
perpendicular a la siguiente recta a la
recta 4 x más bien esto igual acá además
me dicen si la recta l intercepta a la
recta 4 x más igual acá en el punto de
coma
temas uno de coma temas uno lo que me
preguntan es cuál es el valor de t yo lo
que quiero saber es cuánto vale que esto
es lo que quiero saber muy bien y ahora
como los hubo este problema
lo que quiero que notes es que el l es
perpendicular a esta recta y si dos
rectas son perpendiculares entonces qué
pasa con las pendientes
bueno pues las pendientes cumplen que su
multiplicación es igual a menos uno o
que la pendiente de una es igual al
limbo
son multiplicativo negativo de la otra
así que si yo tengo la pendiente de esta
recta y de una forma muy sencilla ya sé
la pendiente de esta recta porque quien
es su pendiente trabajemos con esta
recta la recta 4x
más y
igual acá que pendiente tiene para esto
hay que despejar allí así que déjame
restar 4x de ambos lados de la ecuación
james es igual a menos 4 x más acá ok
esta recta esta recta de aquí estamos
viendo tiene como pendiente a menos
cuatro menos cuatro el valor que está al
lado de la x está su pendiente menos
cuatro bien pero como yo sé que estas
dos rectas son perpendiculares entonces
la recta l tiene como pendiente la
pendiente de la recta l quien es igual
bueno pues a este número hay que
encontrarle su inverso multiplicativo
que es menos un cuarto y cambiarle de
signo es decir la pendiente de la recta
l es un cuarto que es el inverso
multiplicativo negativo de este número
si esta recta tiene como pendiente menos
4 y la pendiente de la recta l es igual
a un cuarto entonces ya se ve
la ecuación de la recta l la recta l
tiene como ecuación james es igual a la
pendiente que es un cuarto que es un
cuarto por x más b pero como pasa por el
origen de vale cero y ya que tengo la
ecuación de la recta l ahora yo lo que
necesito es el valor de t para encontrar
el valor de t
que te parece si sustituimos justo aquí
tenemos el dato de que estas dos rectas
ésta y ésta se intersectan en este punto
este punto vive tanto en una recta como
la otra vive en esta recta pero también
vive en esta otra recta y si vive en la
recta l entonces cumple esta ecuación o
dicho de otra manera cuando x vale te
vale temas uno lleva al dt no lo podemos
meter justo en esta ecuación porque este
punto está en esta recta así que me
quedaría temas 1
1 esto tiene que ser igual a un cuarto a
un cuarto por equis pero x vale te lo
único que estoy haciendo es sustituyendo
el valor de x y el valor de jeff en esta
ecuación de mi recta l y ahora vamos a
despejar a temp para esto vamos a tomar
otro color voy a quitar uno de ambos
lados de esta ecuación menos uno menos
uno y también voy a quitar menos un
cuarto
dt de ambos lados de la ecuación menos
un cuarto de tema
y aquí menos un cuarto dt porque que me
va a quedar de esto bueno pues este
menos uno y este uno se van y me queda t
menos un cuarto de tema lo cual es tres
cuartos de t tres cuartos de t a un
pastel le quitas un cuarto puesto que da
tres cuartos de ese pastel y del otro
lado que te queda un cuarto menos un
cuarto estos dos se van a y solamente te
queda menos uno perfecto ya casi
obtenemos el valor de t hasta ahorita
tenemos que tres cuartos
es igual a menos 1 ahora qué te parece
se multiplicó ambos lados de esta
igualdad por el inverso multiplicativo
de tres cuartos el inverso
multiplicativo de tres cuartos es cuatro
tercios así que voy a multiplicar por
cuatro tercios esto y aquí también por
cuatro tercios lo que hago de un lado lo
hago del otro y aquí este se van con
este este se va con este y me queda
simple y sencillamente que t es igual a
menos cuatro tercios que es justo yo lo
que quería el valor de t es igual a
menos cuatro tercios y por cierto
changos
anarquista perdón perdón estoy fijándome
en los incisos de otro ejercicio ya me
había asustado no no no el inciso a dice
que te vale menos cuatro tercios es el
inciso a y lo puedes verificar en tu
libro ya está la respuesta de este
problema es el inciso am y bueno no me
da tiempo de hacer el problema no me los
18 así que mejor lo voy a hacer en el
siguiente vídeo hasta la próxima